oh my goodness pop and your puppy time
whoa hello everybody hi welcome to the
vlog the reason I'm filming it on my
phone is because unfortunately my
internet seems to be out so I try to
edit this and upload this on my phone
which I have done in a while
so hopefully technology is still
wonderful and able to do that in debt
right pop in yeah right can you get down
please please you're dangerously close
to my balls and I don't appreciate she
has balls seeking pause and that sounds
really weird but it's true
every time she runs up and jumps POD
square into my nuts and it's not funny
and it's not entertaining so hoppy on
pop beat glute pup so hi everybody and
happy fourth of July
um I I wanted to wish everybody happy
for the July you know if you're American
go shoot some fireworks safely because
there's already been some fires here in
LA from people shooting off fireworks
and I don't want to have my house burned
down but also you know I just wanted to
wish you everyone outside America happy
fourth of July use it as an excuse to
have fun and hang out with friends and
family um and I also wanted to say that
uh you know the fourth of July is always
a bit of a somber experience for me and
I don't want anyone to feel you know
like I'm just moping about all day but
the fourth of July is oddly enough the
day that my dad passed away so whenever
I get to the fourth of July I use it as
an excuse to you know look back on my
life and I know I use a lot of excuses
to look back on my life but this one in
particular you know because some people
don't know this I had a life before I
was on YouTube isn't that weird I
existed long before that I was a nerdy
dopey kid all through school everyone
didn't like me at all and I had no
friends that's actually a lie I had lots
of friends but just yesterday I was
looking through old pictures that I had
on Facebook and you know I was just kind
of trolling through the years of baby
March EMU and it was a fun time to see
like the nerd that I was if I was if I
was looking at me back in high school
out of Lee
you stupid nerd oh why don't you go get
your education
you so it's it's always an interesting
experience to look back and I know I
look back a lot but looking back is like
the easiest way that I can you know stay
grounded to what I am now and you know
stay grounded to you know the person
that I've become now and you know stay
grounded to how far I've gone and you
know I I'd always like to think that you
know if my dad could see what I've
accomplished he'd be very proud of Who I
am and what I've become and and you know
what I've accomplished and and at the
end of the day all that is thanks to
know you guys and the support that
you've given me and the opportunities
that you've given me and I know that I
haven't been keeping up with the charity
livestreams I know I haven't been I'm
going to do when when July probably
right before Comic Con comes around it's
just that doing charity livestreams by
myself is a slog it is very very
difficult because when I do a livestream
I want it to be as entertaining as
possible so I'm hoping to either have
some friends over for it maybe Bob and
Wade I don't know they're good they're
very busy so I know that they probably
can't come over all the way to LA but
maybe I could go back home to Cincinnati
and do one because you know that's
that's like what I love I love the
memories I had of doing charity
livestreams in my mom's kitchen this is
good times all around and you know I I
know that I owe it to you guys but also
and not to make an excuse but this these
past two months I've been unbelievably
busy because I've been trying to do
everything that I've already been doing
on YouTube don't lick the wall what are
you doing she's licking the tile here
gross who knows where that's been it's
probably got week old habanero in' and
milk on it so don't do that but you know
i i know i haven't been keeping up with
it but the past two months have been
really really ridiculously busy like for
the past few months i you know i've been
editing myself again
on top of all the other things and all
the other projects that i got going on
so i've been losing sleep constantly and
i don't want you to feel bad for me like
i'm not i'm not sad about any of this
i'm not sad at the fact that I'm busy
I'm not complaining cuz I have an
awesome life and I get to do what I love
um that's not what I'm doing
that you know you know I've been taxed
heavily you know my energy has been
spent in a lot of places but oddly
enough I've been very happy it's
interesting to see because I do read
comments and I do keep up with you guys
I just don't always respond but it's
good to see the response because people
have been people have been noticing you
know you know I've videos have been you
know getting back into the old shape you
know what I mean it cuz it's an
interesting thing because videos are an
emotional experience not always but you
know what I mean but videos you know
it's like a connected experience you
guys when you watch you know you can see
the state of being that I am and people
notice when I'm tired and people notice
when I'm sad and people notice you know
when these things are going on and it's
always interesting to see that feedback
come in live and some people obviously
are wrong about their interpretation but
most people are right and it's just good
to see the response has been very good
to videos lately and response have been
very good to what I've been doing lately
and it's very encouraging for what I'm
gonna be doing in the future so but
things will get better soon and I am
going to comic-con and now that I've
said it out loud I think that's what I
want to do I want to go back to
Cincinnati and I want to do a live
stream because I know I know if I come
over to Cincinnati Wade would love to do
a live stream with me possibly I can't
exactly volunteer for that I have to ask
him first I'd be a really shitty thing
for me to do as a friend to just
volunteer him up for that but you know
maybe maybe I'm doing that anyway hey
Wade you want to do a charity livestream
back in Cincinnati with me and pretty
cool right yeah so I'm gonna be doing
that so if you can write down the
comments suggestions for what the next
charity should be please let me know and
yeah just just thank you guys I hope you
have a wonderful holiday I didn't really
have a main thing that I wanted to talk
about but obviously I was rambling and I
filled up a few minutes anyway but just
you know thank you guys so much and I'm
gonna I'm gonna take today to try to you
know connect with my family again
and you know make sure that they know I
care about them and make sure that they
know like how much I'm grateful for
their support and what I've done in the
past and how grateful I am for your
support for what I've done here and I
just want you guys to know that if me if
me I'm doof and me em can't do this then
you am cam do too you have B success and
do your things and it's just like AI
tried to say that silly because it's a
cliche when I say it at this point you
know that I believe in you guys and that
I truly honestly believe that you guys
can do whatever you put your minds to
but it's true you know it's true I I do
believe in you guys and I do believe in
you guys and I'm grateful for you guys
watching what I do and you know whatever
it may be may be school you know art
YouTube could be it could be a bunch of
things it could be an unlimited number
of things you have so much potential and
there's so many of you I just know that
I believe in you and I believe in what
you're doing and I believe that you know
together this community can do something
really good so anyway
oh uh I'll leave with that cuz hopefully
those words made sense and I'm only
gonna make a fool out of myself the
longer I talk so just thank you guys so
much for watching say bye chica chica
chica look you looking at you looking at
me oh you have kicked your pretty eyes
but just thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye say bye chica no
don't say bye to me say bye to them see
about them to poopoo Oh